Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Brid Love
und ich äh begrüße alle im neuen Jahr 2022, da schreiben wir heute den
Januar. Ja und das ist äh natürlich mal wieder Zeit für ein Update in der Coronakrise mit mir und mit Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Genau. Ein äh Corona-Weekly. Jetzt haben wir Weihnachten hinter uns und diese Zeit, von der man schon vorher wusste, dass man danach noch nicht so sehr viel schlauer sein wird. Was denn nun eigentlich wirklich passiert ist. Gut 7. Januar,
Ich würde sagen, jetzt beginnt so langsam die Zeit, wo man auf die Zahlen schauen kann und vielleicht so ansatzweise ein Gefühl dafür bekommt, wie es eigentlich hätte laufen müssen. Die Erfahrung des letzten Jahres hat ja gezeigt über.
Weihnachten ändert sich sowohl das Verhalten als auch die Arbeitsleistung von Testzentren, Gesundheitsämtern und allen anderen möglichen,
gesellschaftlichen Faktoren, so dass diese permanente.
Metric von Inzidenzen und Fällen und so weiter ähm bisschen ins Wanken kommt und natürlich sind alle so ein bisschen.
So ein Wartemodus äh wann's denn nun richtig losgeht mit OmiCronn.
Ist schon da. Wir wissen bloß noch nicht so hundertprozentig,
Wie sehr und vor allem läuft so ein bisschen die Debatte, die Diskussion da drüber.
Was heißt das jetzt eigentlich für Deutschland ganz konkret? Inwiefern wird's hier so ähnlich laufen wie in anderen Ländern? Inwiefern,
wird's hier vielleicht auch anders laufen, weil's natürlich auch ein paar Unterschiede gibt so, ne. Das mal so vorneweg mit anderen Worten. Wir werden uns auch
dieses Mal ein wenig auf das OmiCrongeschehen konzentrieren, aber ich würde vorschlagen, wie immer, machen wir erstmal hier reinen Tisch und gucken mal, was so jetzt an offiziellen Zahlen
berichtet wird und was sich daraus denn so ablesen lässt.
Ja also hm wir sind jetzt durch,
eine vierte Welle äh durchgegangen auf jeden Fall so, deren Peak äh irgendwann anfangen
Dezember erreicht war, seitdem geht's ja die ganze Zeit äh bergab. Ähm da hat es sich jetzt wieder,
umgekehrt, also seit einer Woche sind wir jetzt wieder steigende Inzidenzen mit einem R-Wert von 1 Kommazwei ungefähr sieben Tage R-Wert und.
Wir hatten auch dann ähm dem Peak bei den Inzidenzen folgend so einen,
Peak mit bis zu ja äh zweieinhalbtausend ungefähr Todesfällen pro Woche.
Ähm so oder in innerhalb von sieben Tagen jeweils. Das ist jetzt auf tausendsiebenhundertsieben in den letzten sieben Tagen gefallen. Also wir hatten da zumindest noch einen Rückgang
so aber der Rückgang verlangsamt sich und das könnte da jetzt auch wieder zu einem
Anstieg kommen was man aber auf jeden Fall sagen kann ist, wenn man.
Den den Peak an Todesfällen in der zweiten Welle sich anschaut, hm.
Dann ist es gegenüber der zweiten Welle ungefähr nur ein Fünftel,
die äh äh der Leute, die sterben so bei gegebener Inzidenz und ähm ja, etwa ein,
Drittel Hälfte bis ein Drittel gegenüber äh dann der Frühjahrswelle und ähm was äh,
ja für wahrscheinlich vor allem auf die Impfungen zurückzuführen.
Ist das jetzt einfach pro Inzidenz gerade weniger Leute sterben. Also zwischen Hälfte und einem Viertel, je nachdem was man so an Altersgruppen äh betrachtet.
Und OmiCon spielt da noch nicht wirklich rein in diese Statistiken.
Bisher. Also ein bisschen, aber äh weil äh nämlich äh typischerweise ungefähr zwanzig Tage vergehen, wenn sich jemand äh infiziert äh bis er dann halt auch äh als
Todesfall gemeldet wird
und ähm ja äh von daher, ich sage mal vor 20 Tagen war jetzt noch nicht so viel um Mikron, dass das diese Zahlen hätte beeinflussen können, aber da kommen wir ja später nochmal äh drauf auf die Frage.
So äh wie wie schlimm äh ist es denn äh unter OmiCron, aber ähm.
Man kann jetzt sagen, durch die Impfungen ist es jetzt äh alles nur zwischen halb und viertel so schlimm äh wie es mal war. Ja.
Plus, was jetzt aber auch noch reinkommt, ist das ganze Thema Boostern, das macht das halt jetzt auch noch. Äh.
Wieder äh will ich sagen schwieriger aber äh ja doch schwieriger eigentlich den Überblick zu behalten oder zu gucken.
Äh welche äh Kräfte äh wirkten da jetzt eigentlich wo, weil auf der einen Seite haben wir nachlassende Immunität, dann haben wir ansteigendes Omega, aber wir haben eben,
äh äh um Mikron.
Sorry, das passiert mir, ja. Ich ich wünsche mir dieses Ende äh so sehr, dass ich irgendwie immer gerne Omega nenne, so äh ja von Alpha bis Omega ähm.
Und insofern sehen wir halt jetzt die Summe eben äh dieser unterschiedlichen Effekte nachlassender Immunität derjenigen, die noch nicht geboostert sind äh äh plus.
Vormarsch von OmiCron, aber auf der anderen Seite jetzt nochmal eine äh sehr viel bessere Immunität,
von geboosterten äh Grade, also das sozusagen der wer jetzt weiß, dass der dritte Shot
eigentlich mit dazugehört zu einer äh vollen Impfserie, wie wir das bei anderen Impfungen auch haben, wo man dreimal impfen muss äh bis halt äh die Immunität ihr Maximum erreicht, die man durch die Impfung erreichen kann.
Also zumindest für für unter 30-jährige gilt es glaube ich, dass also oder gibt es zumindest jetzt diese Sicht, dass
dass dann sozusagen auch schon genug ist. Ja, also dass der Körper einfach ausreichend in Wallung gebracht ist, um auch
äh langfristig dann ähm weiteren Angriffen zu widerstehen für ältere Personen. Da ist man sich noch nicht so sicher und geht generell davon aus, dass da noch mal nachgelegt werden sollte und natürlich
diesen Variantenwechsel und diese doch krasse Eigenständigkeit von äh Omikron
ähm zu deren Herkunft wir vielleicht auch noch mal was sagen, äh sollten nachher
wird's glaube ich so oder so noch auf eine vierte Impfung hinauslaufen, ob die dann so breit angenommen werden wird. Das ist natürlich nochmal eine andere Frage, aber ähm ja ich äh.
Wird sie nehmen.
Ja was können wir sonst noch zu den Zahlen sagen jetzt? Ähm.
Hast du denn noch du hast da noch so ein bisschen aufgesplittet in der Regel.
Ja, wie wie üblich äh dann äh noch mal nach Alter, wie's äh da jetzt aussieht und da ist jetzt grade die Altersgruppe fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig ganz
äh oben ähm ja.
Mit äh ja einer Inzidenz oh ähm ja von fünfhundertfünfzig ungefähr,
und die niedrigste Inzidenz ist grade bei 80 Plus, äh die sich so um die 1hundert bewegt. Also das ist ganz gut gerade, dass ähm bei den älteren ähm die.
Ganz gut durchgeimpft sind, sich grade aber auch die Inzidenzen sehr weit unten bewegen. Interessanterweise kommen dann die Altersgruppe null
bis 4 mit einer Inzidenz so von die 175 hm,
auch deutlich unterdurchschnittlich ja und
so in der Mitte bewegen sich dann die 35 bis 59-jährigen mit so um die 3hundert und.
Die Kinder oder die Schüler mit 5 die fünf bis 14-jährigen dann mit 400 und äh ja schon gesagt äh,
die 15-bis 34-jährigen führen gerade mit
über deutlich über 500. Äh was sicherlich auch wieder verzerrt ist, ein bisschen durch äh die Testregime und die Ferien, weil so dass ich davon ausgehe, dass die Schüler, äh wenn
die Schule wieder losgeht
und getestet wird und die Ergebnisse dieser Tests kommen, dass das dann äh bei den Schülern wieder auch rapide nach oben gehen wird.
Wir dort vermutlich auch sehr sehr viele äh asymptomatisch haben, gerade die gar keinen Anlass hin sich irgendwie testen zu lassen, weil sie keine Beschwerden haben.
Auf jeden Fall ist das Inzidenzgeschehen im Wesentlichen eine Sache der Jüngeren.
Ähm der Gesellschaft. Das kann man, glaube ich, mal so zusammenfassen. Ist jetzt auch nicht wirklich was Neues, aber das wird auf jeden Fall offensichtlich, wenn man sich die Zahlen anschaut, auch wenn man's im Detail alles immer nicht so vergleichen kann.
Ja, die Bundesländer.
Ja in den Bundesländern läuft es jetzt bunt ähm so interessanterweise ist Bremen jetzt ganz nach oben geschossen. Äh also wir haben,
jetzt äh interessanterweise äh so äh an der an der Spitze sind jetzt grade Bremen, Hamburg, Berlin und äh auch äh ja Schleswig-Holstein ähm,
was halt ja wirklich interessant ist, weil die eher so sich sonst im,
mittleren oder unteren Inzidenzbereich aufgehalten haben mutmaßlich könnte es sich,
um einen Omikron
Effekt handeln, aber ähm ja äh bleibt halt zu beobachten. Kann eben auch noch einen Artefakt sein von jetzt Nachholeffekten. Ähm.
Dass äh dort über Weihnachten halt etwas liegengeblieben ist oder die anderen noch nicht mit dem Testen nachgekommen sind. Man weiß es einfach nicht.
Es liegt aber schon an bin ich nahe, weil ähm Bremen ist halt extrem gut geimpft und.
Die sozusagen überhaupt so weit vorne liegen und dass ja vor allem auch schon jetzt seit einer über einer Woche.
Nach oben schießen, das spricht schon sehr für und Hamburg ist ja sozusagen das andere, also so zwei Ballungsgebiete im Norden, die halt nah an Dänemark sind. Aber eben auch.
Nah an Holland in gewisser Hinsicht, ne? Und generell halt Metropolen, wo mehr Reisende hinkommen, während Schleswig-Holstein halt.
Wie hier schon öfter bemerkt, halt recht verteilt ist. Ne, trotzdem betroffen ist.
Ähm gut, ich weiß es natürlich jetzt auch nicht, aber ich gucke mir das an und denke mir so, hm ja okay, da da kommt's her, so oder da da ist es zumindest als erstes hingegangen.
Ja, also es ist die Inzidenzen, gerade alle mit äh ganz viel Fragezeichen äh äh zu betrachten ähm wegen ja,
Anteil wegen Weihnachten und ähm so ja.
Allgemeiner Unsicherheit äh Deutung der Lage.
Ein kleiner Hinweis noch, weil das hatte ich hier in einem äh Artikel.
Bremen ist auch die ähm der Bereich in Deutschland, der keinen Meldeverzug jetzt über Dezember hatte.
Weil sie extra noch mal Personal aufgestockt
haben über Silvester, Neujahr et cetera. Sie haben irgendwie da die Zahl der Mitarbeiter glaube ich teilweise sogar äh verdoppelt und sich auch nochmal Bundeswehrsoldaten rangeholt, weil sie explizit
klare Zahlen haben wollten und ähm,
gehen auch, glaube ich, selber davon aus, dass dass das jetzt im Wesentlichen alles Omikonfälle äh sind, die hier das Ganze vorantreiben.
Ja weil äh wenn man äh nämlich,
aktuell noch und gucken auf die Todesfallinzidenzen äh guckt. Da sind irgendwie Berlin und Schleswig-Holstein äh nach wie vor ganz ganz.
Niedersachsen auch und da sind halt Sachsen und äh Thüringen nach wie vor führend äh so und Sachsen-Anhalt, Brandenburg also da sehen wir so ein bisschen auch, dass das,
Bild vielleicht ein bisschen vor drei Wochen und ähm bleibt jetzt dann ja interessant zu sehen, wie sich das dann entwickeln äh wird ähm über die nächsten drei Wochen,
jetzt die Todesfallinzidenzen.
Sachsen ist fast bei zehn so, ne? Zehn von hunderttausend.
Ja die in sieben Tagen gestorben sind.
Genau so in Schleswig-Holstein mal so im Vergleich dazu 0,vier. Das ist schon ein Riesenunterschied und da merkt man einfach, was äh ab.
Ja. Das kann natürlich auch viel damit zu tun haben, müsste sich das jetzt nach Altersgruppen äh wiederum äh an.
Gucken ähm so, aber äh so so hohe.
Zahlen deuten darauf hin, dass es vor allem dort in der älteren Bevölkerung dann die Inzidenzen höher sein dürften. So, weil die in der jungen Bevölkerung spielen bei der Todesfallinzidenz fast keine Rolle.
So alles unter 60 ist.
Die sind halt schlecht geimpft sind und dann passiert's halt.
Das hat dann wahrscheinlich auch viel ja und es dürfte auch noch viel mit der Impfquote unter den Älteren äh zu tun haben und wie Drosten so schön meint. Wir haben immer noch drei Millionen Ungeimpfte über 60-jährige in Deutschland. Hm.
Ohne Not.
Die Fallsterblichkeit nochmal ausgerechnet oder nachgeschlagen.
Ja äh die habe ich natürlich auch immer so ein bisschen im im Blick. So äh wobei man da eben auch immer äh so die letzten
Angaben so auf die man sich verlassen kann äh liegen dann drei Wochen zurück, also die Fälle so von vor drei Wochen,
und ähm ja äh und die habe ich mir halt für.
Altersgruppe so 80 plus und für 60 bis 69.
Angesehen und bei 80 Plus liegen wir jetzt bei zehn Prozent Fallsterblichkeit
oder äh ja Lagen jedenfalls diejenigen, die sich vor ungefähr drei Wochen äh infiziert haben, äh von denen sind äh zehn Prozent verstorben von den über Achtzigjährigen.
Und ähm.
Bei äh den ja bei den 60 bis79-jährigen äh sind es nur.
In Anführungszeichen eins Komma acht Prozent. Ja ähm das ist also.
Äh da sind wir und äh um das auch noch mal jetzt zu relativieren ähm in der zweiten,
Welle, also vor einem Jahr in der in der großen Welle sind in der Altersgruppe äh so über 20 Prozent äh verstorben, die infiziert waren. Man,
kann also ja gut kann noch überlegen okay wie war's denn mit der mit der Testabdeckung und,
und so äh dunkelziffer aber grundsätzlich äh ist es so, dass durch die Impfungen sich in der Altersgruppe 80 Plus die Sterblichkeit etwa halbiert hat und
bei der Altersgruppe sechzig bis neunundsiebzig sogar ja auf ein Drittel bis ein Viertel,
abgesunken
ist so, also grade in der Altersgruppe scheinen die Impfungen auch hm ja sogar noch noch noch einen höheren Effekt äh zu zu haben, also was den Schutzvorsterblichkeit angeht.
Schutz vor dem Tod äh so äh ja ähm äh was haben wir noch?
Du hast noch Berliner Zahlen zusammengetragen. Gibt's da noch irgendwas Besonderes äh.
Ja in Berlin ist es jetzt so, dass eigentlich in allen Bezirken jetzt die
Zahlen hochgegangen sind und es auch äh ja sich, ich sage mal, zwischen gerade
300 in Marzahn und 670 in Mitte bewegen so und ja dann Neukölln,
Pankow und äh Friedrichshain sind auch alle so über dem Berliner äh Schnitt äh alle bei bei 600und so äh ja.
Übersetzt für Leute, die mit den Stadtteilen in Berlin nicht ganz so äh vertraut sind. Am Rand geht's grad noch so und in der Mitte geht's ab, so. Das kann man glaube ich ganz gut äh so festhalten. Ist auch wenig überraschend.
Ja, aber ähm wenn man sich dann anguckt so äh im,
Lagebericht, was jetzt die Hospitalisierung angeht. Ja, diese berühmte Hospitalisierungsinzidenz hinkt natürlich immer ein bisschen hinterher. Meldetechnisch.
Aber die ist jetzt grade sogar Ampeltechnisch im grünen Bereich. Also ähm irgendwo.
Bei drei Komma acht äh so was auch immer ähm ja, dass das Aussagen äh mag, aber,
Ähm ja nicht wirklich schlimm, trotz äh dieser Rekordinzidenzen äh von,
jetzt seit 500 nach Meldedatum und über ja.
In einigen Bereichen über 6hundert. Die ist weit im roten Bereich, weil da gilt noch irgendwo die hundert, aber ähm ja wie man sieht trotz
äh ja eine eine jetzt fünf sechsfachen Überschreitung
dieses Grenzwertes bei den Inzidenzen scheint die Hospitalisierungsinzidenz noch äh ganz in Ordnung zu sein und auch,
intensiv Auslastung, die es jetzt eher im gelben Bereich bei 18,1 Prozent in Berlin 20 Prozent ist da die rote,
Linie
und äh sie war mal bei 5unddreißig Prozent in der zweiten Welle, also ist jetzt halb so hoch.
Und sagen wie sie mal äh war oder ich ja.
Mal ein bisschen anders dargestellt. Wir haben ungefähr die dreifache Inzidenz von der dritten Welle.
Wir liegen mit der Krankenhaus- und Intensivstationsbelastung leicht unter der.
Dritten Welle. Also es ist schon eine eine Riesenveränderung zum Bemerken und das wird sehr viel mit den Impfungen zu tun haben.
So äh noch nicht unbedingt mit OmiCron, auch wenn das vielleicht auch schon mit reinspielt,
Ne, weil Leute, die also Omikontin ist hier, Omikon wird eine gewisse Verbreitung haben. Wahrscheinlich liegt sie schon über fünfzig Prozent, aber äh und Leute werden auch schon,
krank damit. Ne, nur eben nicht so viele. Also äh auch wenn das jetzt sozusagen noch keine.
Komplette Omikron-Lage ist, ist sie auf jeden Fall schon mal Omikron unterfüttert und ich äh.
Macht so den Eindruck, als ob wir hier einen Trend nach unten grade sehen, der gerade beginnt.
Ja, also zumindest äh ich also ähm äh zumindest äh sieht es.
Im Moment noch nicht katastrophal aus. Also ich würde sagen, insgesamt bewegt sich alles so im gelben Bereich, wenn man's jetzt mal im Ampelfarben oder Warnstufen
ähm irgendwo ähm ausdrücken möchte und.
Ansonsten ja hat man auch das Gefühl so alle sind so ein bisschen brace for omikron
Impact äh so. Keiner weiß genau, wie wie wie schlimm der Aufprall jetzt werden wird. Es gibt viele hoffnungsvolle Zeichen
so, auch weil es sich bei uns nicht ganz so schnell ausbreitet, hat er schon und auch in den
anderen Ländern ist es jetzt nicht zu Zusammenbrüchen von Gesundheitssystemen gekommen und äh selbst nicht in in in Ländern, die viel weniger Maßnahmen
aktiv hatten oder haben als wir. Also insofern äh ja besteht Hoffnung äh so, dass.
Nur dass die halt bisher die Länder, die wir bisher vergleichen konnten, alle eine sehr viel höhere Impfquote haben und da eine sehr viel höhere Durchinfektions äh Quote
hatten und von daher fehlt uns so ein bisschen der passende Vergleich. Ne, also mit mit unserer schlechten Impfquote stehen wir einfach so ein bisschen doof da.
Und äh es schauen jetzt gerade eigentlich eher alle auf Deutschland und gucken mal, was was so mit einer niedrigen Impfquote passiert, wenn sie auch Mikron aufschlägt.
Ja und ähm da ist wohl auch die Experteneinschätzung und dann sind wir jetzt schon tief im äh Thema fast schon drin.
Ähm aber weil weil's halt auch eine Zahl ist, passt es vielleicht. Ähm.
Also die besten Einschätzungen äh im Moment für wie wie schlimm ist denn jetzt.
Im Vergleich zu Delta, was jetzt die Hospitalisierung angeht, dann äh schwanken die Zahlen, je nachdem zwischen es ist genauso schlimm bis.
Ist
ungefähr ähm dreißig Prozent besser, also dreißig Prozent weniger Hospitalisierungen. So, das ist jetzt kein gewaltiger Faktor, ja? Also es ist äh macht jetzt aus
Omikron
äh nicht einfach einen Schnupfen für Ungeimpfte, ja, sondern ähm ja, sondern das ist halt ein Zwei-Drittel-Corona, wenn man so will. Ja.
Und äh also auch nicht so viel so viel harmloser oder wie gesagt eventuell wie wie Delta eben,
auch in und von daher das Idealszenario, um jetzt schon mal.
Zukunft kurz vorwegzunehmen, was ich so sehe, ist, dass man möglichst seine Bevölkerung.
So weit es geht durchgeboostert haben möchte.
Um dann äh ja äh Omikron äh durchlaufen zu lassen, was sich dann wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich,
aufhalten äh lässt. Ähm gut, wenn's dann wärmer wird äh äh kann man damit rechnen, dass es auch wieder wie jedes Jahr äh dann zurückgehen wird, aber wahrscheinlich.
Ideal wäre es äh ja, alle, alle zu Boostern äh möglichst.
Und äh ja äh dann zu gucken, dass das äh Omi-Kron ähm.
Ja äh sein sein Lauf äh läuft, muss den jetzt nicht
befördern äh unbedingt, aber aus meiner Sicht auch jetzt nicht irgendwie auf äh Teufel kommen raus.
In so einem Szenario dann zu versuchen die Ausbreitung zu äh verhindern.
Nicht viel bringen. Also mit anderen Worten, wir brauchen keinen Lockdown. Um das mal festzuhalten, ganz neuer Trend hier.
Ja, das, das, das L-Wort ist halt eh mittlerweile äh schwer zu sagen, was ist denn
äh eigentlich jetzt jetzt Lockdown und da fand ich auch interessant Christian Drosten äh meinte, dass halt jetzt vor allem Schulschließungen,
so der Faktor sind, der tatsächlich die Ausbreitung,
am meisten äh unterbindet und zwar aus zwei Gründen, erstens weil die Schüler dann tatsächlich sich nicht in der Schule treffen, aber auch weil die Eltern dann gezwungen sind, mehr zu Hause zu bleiben so. Deswegen.
Ist das wohl dass die größte Wirkung und er meinte dann auch und es ist die Maßnahme, die äh immer als letzte gezogen.
So aus.
Werden sollte.
Äh wird äh so über das werden sollte, da hat er sich jetzt, glaube ich, nicht konkret. Er sagt nur, so sieht's epidemiologisch.
Aus äh aber politisch ist äh halt da der erklärte Wille, muss man sagen, die Schulen wirklich als letztes zuzumachen.
Ja.
Ja, weil man halt gesehen hat, was das eben was das für Auswirkungen hat so, ne? Und äh in der Debatte dadrum.
Wird natürlich dann von äh entsprechenden.
Befürwortern äh von Schulschließungen halt dann schnell geschlussfolgert, dass das ja nur wegen der Wirtschaft gemacht wird, ne, weil das natürlich dann auch gleich.
Entsprechenden Auswirkungen hat.
Nicht ganz so krass formulieren. Ich denke, es ist schon eine Gesamtabwägung so. Ähm der Belastung, auch der Kinder letzten Endes ja auch mit, ne?
Gut, das.
Es ist so ein bisschen wie die Wahl zwischen Pest und Cholera äh und dementsprechend verläuft halt auch die äh äh politische Debatte, weil dann äh ich sage mal die eine Seite sagt,
miesen äh Cholera Verbreiter und äh die andere Seite, ja ihr ihr äh äh.
Pestignoranten, ja.
Ja, es ist ist schwierig da zu vermitteln, ne.
Beide haben recht, ja. Es ist beides irgendwie Mist äh äh so auf der einen Seite den äh die Kinder äh sagen dann covid auszusetzen,
ungeschützt, ungeimpft ähm ja ähm das ist so die die eine Sache und,
die andere Sache ist, was wir eben auch wissen, äh so sie zu Hause zu lassen, hat halt auch äh sehr negative Effekte für Gesundheit, Entwicklung und.
Familie, ja.
Familie,
äh so und das ist halt schwer gegeneinander auf äh zu wägen. In der ersten Welle war es noch so, okay, da wussten wir auch noch nicht so viel über die
Auswirkungen jetzt von Lockdowns sage ich mal, dass man halt mal nur sagen konnte, gut
vermutlich ist es für das auch nicht gut werden, aber wir sehen auf der einen Seite, wie viel Leute sterben, wenn wir die Zahlen nicht unten halten und auf der anderen Seite äh haben wir ja jetzt eine eher abstrakte
Bedrohung, aber äh diese,
abstrakte Bedrohung, äh sage ich mal, die kann jetzt auch zunehmend eher mit Zahlen belegt werden, sodass man jetzt schon glaube ich auch langsam anfangen kann, rationale Abwägungen wirklich vorzunehmen.
Äh und ähm
Das heißt, da hat sich die Situation eben auch etwas geändert. Wir kennen jetzt die negativen Auswirkungen von Lockdowns ein bisschen besser.
Lass uns mal noch die Zahlen äh zu Ende bringen, vielleicht noch kurz was zur Kampagne äh sagen und dann stürzen wir uns mal voll auf die ganze.
Äh Debatte und Wasser vor allem an neuen Erkenntnissen dahergekommen ist. Dann gibt's ja schon ein paar äh interessante Sachen. Aber wir sollten vielleicht nochmal kurz die Test
äh Situation anschauen.
Mhm. Ja und bei den Testzahlen haben wir jetzt äh wieder einen.
Gerade einen neuen Rekord bei der positiven Quote erreicht
was sicherlich auch mit im Rückgang der Tests auch zu tun hat, die Zahl der Tests ist äh äh deutlich zurückgegangen, aber dafür war fast jeder vierte Test, also vieren
äh in dem Moment was ist es, ne nicht jeder äh fünfte, also 1undzwanzig,fünf acht Prozent der Tests äh waren positiv, also mehr als jeder fünfte äh Test.
Der gemacht wurde war positiv ja,
und äh insofern würde ich mal sagen auf jeden Fall trotz der ganzen Testeinbrüche und Rückgang ist der Anstieg der Inzidenz.
Äh real jetzt wieder und wird wahrscheinlich,
Eher äh ja noch noch unterrepräsentiert, gerade in den RKI-Zahlen, das heißt äh wahrscheinlich äh wenn ich mir so jetzt die nächsten ein, zwei Wochen angucke, werden wir in den nächsten ein, zwei Wochen
die Zahlen nach oben schießen sehen würde ich mal vermuten.
Würde ich auch vermuten. Es ist auf jeden Fall die höchste positiv Quote, die wir bisher hatten.
In der gesamten Pandemie. Das äh sagt, glaube ich, schon so einiges aus. Und ich denke, wer wer jetzt irgendwie erwartet, die Zahlen würden jetzt noch zurückgehen oder sich irgendwie einpendeln. Also da habe ich jetzt relativ wenig Hoffnung.
Dunkelziffer hast du auch noch eine Einschätzung?
Ja, ich habe äh auf eine äh schon ein paar Monate alte äh Studie vom vom,
RKI äh ähm auf die bin ich gestoßen.
Die so verschiedene Studien ähm also Zero-Studien zusammenfasst, wo man einfach geguckt hat, wie viel Leute haben denn ähm
einfach äh ja wie sieht die Zero-Prävalenz aus, also wie viel Leute waren schon infiziert und wie viele,
positive Tests gab es und daraus eben einen Untererfassungsfaktor beziehungsweise dass wir immer Dunkelziffer nennen und.
Leider äh scheinten die meisten Studien ähm nur bis,
Jahr bis zum Sommer 2021 durchgeführt worden zu sein. Es gibt wahrscheinlich noch mehr Studien nehme ich an, aber das ist sozusagen die letzte Studie dort bis ausm August.
2021 in Chemnitz durchgeführt worden und,
Ich fand das nur deswegen interessant, weil man jetzt ungefähr was über einen Range
aussagen kann, also den Bereich äh wie denn die Dunkelziffer dann variiert und die variiert halt regional und variiert halt auch auch zeitlich
aber ähm ja und sagen,
niedrigste Wahl irgendwann mal in in äh Osnabrück beziehungsweise auch Berlin Mitte irgendwo bei eins Komma drei, eins ,vier und dann so recht früh,
oder im im 2020 ähm.
Im zwischen März und und Mai in der in der in der ersten Welle kam man dann so in Gangelt oder Kupferzell oder Tirschenreuth auf Faktor fünf.
Etwa, das heißt, in dem Bereich scheint sich das bewegt zu haben.
Zwei und 5 sozusagen.
Zwischen zwei und fünf oder eins Komma fünf und fünf so äh regional und zeitlich ähm was man da auch aber wieder sieht ist ich frage mich warum man so was nicht,
Für jeden Landkreis.
Periodisch macht, ja. Stattdessen haben wir hier so eine wilde Auswahl mit einzelnen Studien in bestimmten Städten wurde es mal wiederholt, wurde es vielleicht mal zweimal gemacht, aber.
Ansonsten äh ja ein wirklich wildes Kraut und Rüben äh den zweimal bundesweit.
Da lag es beides mal knapp unter zwei. Der Faktor. Ja. Und.
Wir hatten den ja irgendwann auch mal reduziert so aber,
furchtbar einfach. Also es ist äh nach wie vor alles furchtbar und auch, dass es ja, dass das nicht fortgeschrieben wird oder dass man da nicht nicht regelmäßig draufguckt oder so, na. Gut.
Da regen wir uns jetzt nicht mehr groß drüber auf. Das kennen wir ja alles schon.
Ja. Aber man findet, man findet immer wieder äh neue Güllegruben, so. Wo man sich dann fragt, ja, das geht doch eigentlich besser.
Haben Sie mal äh eine Schätzung gewagt
ähm wie viele Leute denn so insgesamt bisher gestorben sind in der ganzen Pandemie weltweit. Das ist natürlich eine extrem schwer zu bestimmende Zahl. Ja, also nicht nur die Zahlen in Deutschland sind äh schwammig.
International natürlich auch und ja die Schätzung geht so auf irgendwie achtzehn.
18,3 Millionen äh tote Menschen, die sozusagen an covid gestorben sind.
Da kann man jetzt auch mit draus machen was man will äh ist auf jeden Fall schon mal.
Signifikanter äh Vorfall, ne auch wenn man sagen muss, dass die Weltbevölkerung insgesamt in dem selben Zeitraum um mehr als 18 Millionen gestiegen ist.
Ist ja jetzt kein Null-Summen-Spiel. Ja. Na gut, dann ähm.
Noch mal ein paar Worte zur äh Impfkampagne. So viel lässt sich dazu auch nicht wirklich sagen.
Wenn man jetzt mal so guckt wie sich das so entwickelt hat, also wir hatten ja vor Weihnachten diesen Boosteransturm, also so bis bis Weihnachten hin, da haben da so viele Leute nochmal
äh Gas gegeben, wahrscheinlich auch mit äh Blick auf Weihnachten.
Allerdings ist die gesamte Beschleunigung der Impfkampagne, also die tatsächlich mehr gerauscht hat als jemals zuvor, also in dieser ganzen Boosterwelle wurden also täglich sehr viel mehr Impfungen durchgeführt als zu besten Junizeiten.
Und ähm das gilt aber auch eigentlich wirklich nur für die Boosterei. Also die Erstimpfung die hatten so na ja Ende November und Mitte Dezember nochmal so ein paar kleine Mini-Peaks sind aber da irgendwie auch,
nicht wirklich auf nennenswerte äh Zahlen gekommen. Ja und ähm sind dann auch wieder abgefallen und Zweitimpfungen,
dann natürlich entsprechend hin und her. Sprich das ganze Impfgeschehen ist derzeit eigentlich im Wesentlichen ein Booster-Impfgeschehen und Deutschland tut relativ wenig dafür, um die sogenannte Impflücke wirklich erfolgreich zu schließen.
Mal gucken, ob sich das vielleicht nach Weihnachten wieder erholt. Insgesamt sind die ist die Angebotssituation so aus meiner Erfahrung her ganz gut. Also wir hatten natürlich im Dezember so.
Der Preis noch heiß war und alles ähm gut besucht war ähm sollte jetzt eigentlich jeder in der Lage sein irgendwie einen Impftermin zu finden auch kurzfristig eben auch für für Kinder, für jüngere generell.
Ja dann.
Kann man jetzt äh mal festhalten, also derzeit haben wir 17,sechs Prozent der Bevölkerung mindestens doppelt geimpft und einundvierzig.
Dreifach geimpft. Ja, Impf-Dashboard wird ja nur noch schön noch dazugeschrieben. Ja, das RKI geht davon aus, dass die Zahlen um fünf Prozentpunkte höher liegen.
Gut, lassen wir sie fünf Prozent höher liegen, dann sind wir irgendwie auch erst bei äh fünfundsiebzig, sechsundsiebzig äh Prozent. Auch das reicht halt äh hinten und vorne äh nicht.
Das lässt's halt ja zwanzig Millionen. Gut, da sind ein paar, die nicht geimpft werden können. Also die äh Allerjüngsten halt.
Da drin, aber das sind dann natürlich trotzdem irgendwie zwanzig Millionen.
Die noch ungeimpft sind, wenn ich das mal so eben im Kopf äh überschlage und ja.
Dann ähm,
Genau. Also was ich aber bemerkenswert finde, ist, dass jetzt so ein bisschen Musik reingekommen ist bei der STIKO, also da scheint es dann doch ein Sinneswandel gegeben zu haben, inwiefern der mit Karl Latterbach zusammenhängt, kann ich nicht äh beurteilen, aber,
so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob jetzt hier äh mal ein wenig ähm aufgeräumt wurde
erinnern uns, die STIKO war immer sehr zurückhaltend im Erweitern von Empfehlungen, insbesondere was die Boosterei betrifft und äh das hat ja auch der Mehrens teilweise selbst jetzt schon zugegeben, dass sie da wohl zu konservativ an die Sache rangegangen sind. Jetzt noch vor Weihnachten,
haben sie dann eben die offizielle Empfehlung, also der STIKO, ja, für alle auf äh Booster nach drei Monaten runtergesetzt. Das ist jetzt so der der der Konsens, an dem wird sich glaube ich auch erstmal nichts viel äh ändern.
Ähm soll demnächst dann auch noch die.
Doppelte Impfung nur noch sechs Monate gültig sein, also wenn man seine Zweitimpfung wenn die sechs Monate her ist, dann ist gilt man sozusagen nicht mehr als vollständig geimpft.
Und auch diese Zertifikatsprüfung, also das Zertifikat selber, die da ausgegeben sind, die sind ja äh im Prinzip erst mal alle ein Jahr gültig.
Da wird dann wohl auf Seiten der Checker-Apps äh diese Zertifikats-Laufzeit noch mal auf neun Monate runtergetrimmt. Ähm ob das jetzt viel bringen wird, weiß ich nicht, aber das ist auf jeden Fall das, was äh passieren wird.
Was dazu vielleicht noch passt an der Stelle ist, äh dass man äh wohl
äh seit heute auch grade äh ja zwei G Plus statt zwei G äh beschlossen hat was halt äh,
im Wesentlichen für Restaurants, Kneipen, Bars und Cafés. Ähm.
Auch noch mit Test noch mal.
Ja, allerdings nur für doppelt Geimpfte und Genesene. Für drei für geboosterte äh wiederum
äh äh so entfällt dann die Testpflicht, aber nur noch für geboosterte. Im Moment ist es ja so, dass auch für ungebosterte äh so die,
entfällt und das äh soll wohl dann äh ja demnächst losgehen.
Das gilt teilweise schon. Also Niedersachsen äh äh galt das jetzt äh schon über Weihnachten, das weiß ich. Das habe ich mitbekommen und ähm ja, ob das so sehr viel bringen wird, weiß ich nicht, aber na ja gut, die Anreize steigen.
Na ja, es ist ist er erhöht jetzt den den den Druck äh sagen oder den Anreiz, wie immer man das nennen will, äh sich Boostern äh zu lassen. Das ist es im Wesentlichen ja.
Negativen Anreiz. Genau.
Ja, inwiefern das Imperangebot jetzt für die äh kleineren äh von fünf bis 11 angenommen wird, ähm das muss man mal sehen, aber ich denke, dass sie, also ich habe so Einschätzungen gehört, keine wirklich äh guten Zahlen, dass so ungefähr die Hälfte der Erstimpfung, die wir jetzt sehen, eben
im Bereich fünf bis elf sind mit anderen Worten, dass,
Eigentlich jetzt auch noch mal runter von den Altersgruppen, die eigentlich äh mal zuerst Impfung schreiten sollten, die also nach wie vor da zurückhaltend sind offensichtlich ähm.
Hilft da nicht sehr viel mehr als eine Impfpflicht, wenn überhaupt noch irgendwas hilft.
Äh hier in Berlin haben sie teilweise versucht, äh ein Impfangebot an den Schulen zu machen. Das wurde irgendwie kaum genutzt. Keine Ahnung, woran das lag, ob das schlecht organisiert war oder ob's da einfach wieder ob das Problem dann die Eltern sind, ähm keine Ahnung,
andere Eltern, die ich wiederum kenne, haben sich sehnsüchtig nach einem Impftermin äh umgeschaut.
Aber eigentlich auch alle einen gefunden und jetzt warten sie halt auch auf die Zweit äh Impfung, um sich dann auch wieder äh mehr entspannen zu können in der Schule.
Diese Impfpflicht kommt jetzt mehr und mehr in die Diskussion. Impfpflicht wird auch äh gefordert vom Ethikrat.
Er spricht sich mehrheitlich äh für die Impfpflicht aus. Ja? Verlangt allerdings begleitende Maßnahmen.
Die auch ganz sinnvoll äh erscheinen. Äh zum Beispiel direkte Einladung mit personalisierten Terminen. Also nach dem Motto, wenn schon Impfpflicht, dann müsste aber auch mal.
Müsst ihr euch auch mal mal kümmern und und die Leute einfach direkt hier mit hier ist dein Termin, komm einfach rum, zack zack zack ne äh sie fordern auch ein datensicheres nationales Impfregister, sicherlich ein Streitpunkt, ich persönlich.
Denke ja, dass es auch not tut sozusagen. Das haben wir einfach gesehen. Wir haben einfach.
Zu schlechte Übersicht da drüber, was äh und wer jetzt einfach äh geimpft ist. Ähm.
Ja ein umfassendes Beratungsangebot und wertschätzende Kommunikation wird hier auch noch äh gefordert, dass wir unterstreichen ja freie Wahl des Impfstoffs ist eh klar und ähm,
flächendeckend ausreichend Impfstellen. Logisch.
Trotz gibt's auch schon Leute, die dagegen geklagt haben. Also es gibt eine Klage vom Bundesverfassungsgericht. Die jetzt gegen diese Impfpflicht in äh für Gesundheits- und Pflegeeinrichtungen, also für Beschäftigte in den Gesundheits- und Pflegeeinrichtungen.
Geklagt haben, da muss man mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt, dass es wohl irgendwie auch Eilantrag klar ähm da ist aber.
Wahrscheinlich erst im März mit einem Ergebnis zu rechnen. Das.
Weiß ich äh oder nee warte mal, nee, bis Mitte März ist ja die Impfpflicht inwiefern der ein Eilantrag muss ja schneller entscheiden. Also müssen wir mal gucken, äh was dabei rauskommt. Keine Ahnung. Ähm.
Würde ich ja nur begrüßen, wenn das Bundesverfassungsgericht hier an der Stelle auch mal klarstellt, dass das irgendwie okay ist, weil ich können wir ehrlich gesagt tief vorstellen, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht da Zweifel hat, weil das hatten wir alles schon mal und das.
Geht meiner Meinung nach aus der Verfassung vor.
Na ja, ich also so meine Sicht,
auf die Dinge äh ist eher, dass ähm jetzt sicherlich eine eine berufsbezogene Impfpflicht.
So, dass es äh hatten wir, glaube ich, dass es klar, dass Macht Sinn, das das kann man
von jemandem verlangen, wird halt äh von Seeleuten und Soldaten äh schon immer verlangt und beim Reisen auch. Aber.
So tatsächlich meine Meinung, was jetzt,
speziell Corona betrifft und dann die gesundheitlichen Auswirkungen so sind die für, ich sage mal unter 35-Jährige äh jetzt in der Regel nicht,
so, dass ich äh also sie sind sinnvoll natürlich
So es helfen auch bei unter 35-jährigen aber die sind aus meiner Sicht nicht in dem Maße äh gesundheitlich bedroht, dass das eine Impfpflicht rechtfertigen.
Dass es so meine
Sicht der Dinge und ich kann mir auch ganz gut vorstellen, dass auch verfassungs äh Richter, was jetzt eine allgemeine Impfpflicht,
angeht äh zu so einer Einschätzung gelangen könnten. So weil unter 35-jährigen dann wieder für das Gesundheitssystem eine besondere Belastung äh äh darstellen noch
Die Mortalität äh in dem in dem Bereich.
Wie äh ja in einer Größenordnung, wo man sagen könnte, das musste das kann die Gesellschaft jetzt nicht nicht tragen, ja. Also das so sehe ich das. Ja.
Gut, aber ist ja jetzt auch nix Neues. Also ich meine, so Impfpflicht gab's äh in in in Deutschland schon.
Ja ja äh bei aber das waren dann in der Regel eben auch Erkrankungen, äh wo,
du dann äh zehn, zwanzig, dreißig Prozent, fünfzig Prozent äh so schwere gesundheitliche Schäden davon getragen haben. Ja ähm.
Aber bei Corona
haben wir halt Schäden in der Größenordnung wirklich nur bei älteren äh und das ist so ein bisschen der Unterschied.
Aus meiner Sicht zu anderen Impfpflichten, die wir die wir hatten. Es hat keine Frage, dass es trotzdem sinnvoll ist und dass man trotzdem ähm
dafür werben sollte und äh ja ich das jedem auch nur raten kann, sich
impfen äh zu lassen, auch als junger Mensch, aus ganz vielen Gründen so, weil die Impfung eben auch bei jungen Menschen ähm weniger gesundheitsschädlich ist als eine Infektion sein kann.
Aber jetzt in absoluten Zahlen oder oder Anteilen
so wie gesagt bei unter 35 so äh eine eine Impfpflicht fände ich nicht wirklich angesichts der der der Parameter angemessen.
Aber ich kann mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen, dass das äh äh.
Verfassungsgericht an der Stelle wirklich so im Detail sich jetzt solche Aspekte anschaut, die ja äh auch gewisser Hinsicht eine extrem volatile äh
Informationen darstellen, ja, dieses Jahr sind morgen schon wieder ändern kann und äh ob's da genug
Gründe gibt, sondern ich denke das Verfassungsgericht wird generell eher entscheiden so darf
Eine Bundesregierung vorausgesetzt, sie meint die richtigen Zahlen äh und Risikoeinschätzungen zu haben, darf sie das grundsätzlich tun.
Das ist ja eigentlich der Punkt. Ist ist sozusagen so etwas mit der Verfassung vereinbar? Eine andere Frage hat ein Verfassungsgericht in dem Sinne überhaupt nicht zu beantworten. Und da kann ich mir einfach nicht vorstellen, dass sie das machen. Es kann schon sein, dass sie bestimmte.
Parameter aufstellen und sagen, so das und das und das, das muss gewährleistet sein, das muss berücksichtigt sein.
Das muss irgendwie klargestellt sein, das muss deklariert sein. Darüber muss beschlossen worden sein, da muss es Zahlen geben. Aber sie werden auf gar keinen Fall sagen, dass es jetzt irgendwie nicht geht oder so.
Nee, aber ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, also wenn sie sich das genauer angucken, dass sie zu dem Schluss kommen, also äh ja
ab 5unddreißig ist angemessen oder ab äh weiß ich nicht irgend einem anderen Alter vielleicht sogar, dass sie sagen ab 60 äh wahrscheinlich werden sie dann eher sagen ab 35 nehme ich an weil.
Und ich kann mir äh tatsächlich nur auch nur schwer vorstellen, dass sie äh also,
können ja nicht bis null runtergehen, das ist auch logisch beziehungsweise
Äh ja ich ich glaube auch nicht, dass sie sozusagen die Impfpflicht für Kinder also dass sie äh wie weit sie da runtergehen weiß ich nicht, aber kann ich mir vorstellen, dass hier auch die die Kinder ausnehmen äh könnten, das Verfassungsgericht davon.
Gut
Ich wollte auch keine großen Prognosen hier anstellen. Ich wollte nur sagen, dass es das, was passiert ist. Also äh so eine Klage gibt es. Wir werden äh in den nächsten Wochen, nach ein, zwei Monaten auf jeden Fall äh davon hören und dann werden wir sehen, wie es ist, ne. Allerdings ist die Impfpflicht für diese Berufe
beschlossene Sache derzeit und gilt ab März. Das heißt, die Leute müssen sich jetzt im Prinzip auch impfen lassen, wenn sie denn dann äh.
Hier ihren Job behalten wollen. Kommen wir zur OmiCronn.
Omikronen, Omikronen, Omikronen. Ähm.
Ja, ein bisschen hatten wir ja schon das Pulver, das Omikron-Pulver verschossen. Äh stückweise im Laufe der Sendung, aber äh ja äh ein bisschen was haben wir glaube ich noch.
Auf jeden Fall, also
Grundsätzlich äh kann man erstmal voranstellen so Daten äh über die Verbreitungsgeschwindigkeit in Deutschland. Das äh hat sich ja schon abgezeichnet bei dem, weil wir's bisher gesagt haben, sind noch alle sehr wacklig. Das hat natürlich damit zu tun, dass wir eben
nicht sehr viel sequenzieren und dass die Daten, wenn sie denn erfasst werden, auch nicht unbedingt gut veröffentlicht werden.
Ähm Cornelius Römer äh der auch als Journalist TV berichtet, der,
Mainz gäbe keinen wirklich guten Grund, warum zum Beispiel nicht diese äh Daten der Labore äh einfach strategisch eingesammelt werden, weil das ist ja im Prinzip eine Information, die vergleichsweise zweifelsfrei anfällt.
Ne, also.
Da müsste dann wahrscheinlich jemand wieder einen Brief schreiben und den Leuten erklären, wie sie das machen und dann müsste irgendwie IT angepasst werden und.
Ja gut, aber ich meine im Jahr zwei äh ja also ich meine wir machen's okay wir machen's jetzt noch nicht ganz zwei Jahre den ganzen Sport so aber langsam,
Auch ein bisschen ungehalten äh werden. Also ich zumindest. Ähm ja. Es schien Tagesferien nochmal kurz erklärt, dass es halt
wenn halt ein PCR-Test gemacht wird, wird eben auf verschiedene Bereiche getestet. Das ist ja der auf
covid angepasste Test, der auch so über die Zeit immer ein wenig noch modifiziert worden ist, um mit den mit den Varianten und mit den Mutationen mitzuhalten. Wie oft das geschehen ist, kann ich nicht sagen, aber
sicherlich auch statt, aber äh,
schon wie bei der Alpha-Variante kann man eben die Omikron-Variante sehr gut daran erkennen, dass der halt derzeit verwendete
in diesem sogenannten Bereich
eben eine Target-Felge hat, also da quasi nicht anschlägt, während die anderen anschlagen. Sodass man immer noch weiß, ja okay, hier ist genug Covid, weil
anderen Merkmale sind einfach klar. Nur dieser eine äh der greift eben bei dieser Variante nicht und dann kann man halt sowohl sehen, dass es halt ein positiver Test ist.
Als eben auch mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit Omicron.
Richtig genau, was es ist und in welchem Zustand sich die jeweils getestete OmiCon Variante in dem Moment da, wo man testet, befindet, das geht dann eben nur mit Sequenzierung, aber im Prinzip wäre das halt eine schnelle.
Also wir wissen nicht so richtig viel über die Verbreitungsgeschwindigkeit in Deutschland derzeit und wir gehen eben davon aus, dadurch, dass wir Maßnahmen haben und äh einfach ein paar Sachen in Deutschland dann doch anders gehandhabt worden sind in den letzten äh Wochen und Monaten.
Eben nicht ganz so schnell gehen wird. Da, wo es allerdings durchrauscht, da rauscht es dann eben richtig durch. Also in UK.
Dänemark und so weiter zeichnet sich einfach ab, so,
zwei, drei Tage und man man ist sozusagen schon hat schon wieder so einen Generationszyklus durch. Das heißt, der Virus schlägt extrem schnell an, ist extrem schnell
breitet und äh man ist extrem schnell,
infektiös und kann's weiter reichen. Und durch diese hohe Geschwindigkeit, wenn man halt überhaupt gar keine Maßnahmen ergreift, dann kann's halt sehr schnell gehen.
Der anderen Seite, in dem Moment, wo man Maßnahmen ergreift, ist so ein schnelllebiger
Virus auch relativ gut aufzuhalten, das heißt in dem Moment, wo man wirklich mit Masken rangeht, mit Abstand rangeht, mit äh Veranstaltungsvermeidung et cetera kann man auch omigran,
im Griff halten. Man wird's nicht vollständig aufhalten können, aber man wird's auf jeden Fall verzögern können und so würde ich eigentlich auch derzeit die Strategie Deutschlands mal beschreiben, was äh Lauterbach da so im Wesentlichen vorhat.
Wenn man jetzt.
Zurückguckt. Ich meine wir haben nur wöchentliche Zahlen jetzt von den letzten äh sechs Wochen
so seit KW 46 und da kann man sich einfach die Anzahl der Fälle angucken und stellt dann fest, dass es sich
ungefähr pro Woche verdreifacht hat, die Zahl der Fälle manchmal vervierfacht, manchmal nicht ganz verdreifacht, aber das sind so die.
Größenordnung jede Woche, dreimal so viele äh Omikronenfälle nach einer Woche. Das heißt.
Marschiert jetzt,
absoluten Zahlen halt schon hier durch und dass trotz obwohl wir jetzt schon eine ganze Menge eigentlich auch an
Maßnahmen haben, so wie äh Masken und äh Impfung und so und
Ähm jede Menge testen, aber äh all das reicht ganz offensichtlich nicht aus bisher um Mikron wirklich
Jahr zurückzudrängen äh aber es scheint etwas langsamer bei uns anzuwachsen als in England oder in Dänemark. Das hatten wir glaube ich schon. Aber Faktor drei pro Woche ungefähr ist so.
Bei uns der Fall.
Ja ähm haben wir noch was zum zum zur Ausbreitung,
zu zu sagen. Also es gibt vor allem viele neue Erkenntnisse zu wie sich denn Omikron so generell verbreitet und warum es eigentlich so schnell ist.
Was es eben auch wirklich bewirkt und äh vor allem gibt es eine interessante These jetzt, wo es herkommt.
Habt ihr das auch schon äh gesehen hast, wenn man sich den Variantenbaum anschaut und guckt, welche Variante stammt eigentlich von was ab?
Dann ähm sieht man halt so, aha, okay, Delta,
Basiert halt äh also alles passiert natürlich auf dem Wildtyp so,
und ähm Beta ist so ein eigener Strang, Alpha ist so ein äh eigener äh Strang äh aber Delta zum Beispiel basiert halt dann äh schon auf anderen Varianten und man hat halt vor allem,
gesehen, wie die sich entwickelt haben. Die kamen nicht so richtig aus dem Nichts. Eine kleine Ausnahme ist Alpha. Das hatte auch so einen so einen so einen Moment, so ähnlich wie Omikron, als das rauskam, war man überrascht über die,
hoher,
Verbreitungsgeschwindigkeit relativ kein Vergleich zu Omicroin jetzt, ne, aber damals war ja Alpha sozusagen extrem bedrohlich, weil es sich so schnell verbreitet im Vergleich zum Wildtyp.
Und auch da hat so die Sequenzierungsanalyse gesagt so aha relativ viele Mutationen, die wir so vorher noch nicht gesehen haben.
Also auf einmal finden diese nicht statt.
Die müssen irgendwo stattgefunden haben und es ist, glaube ich, nie so richtig geklärt worden bei Alpha, was man da so angenommen hat, wo es denn jetzt nun wirklich,
gefunden hat und wir hatten ja hier auch schon mal über die drei möglichen Ansätze äh gesprochen, was so sein kann
was eben so eine Variante, die so auf einmal aus dem Nichts hochmutiert auftaucht, was mit der eigentlich passiert ist und dann gibt's halt so die These, na ja okay, das war jetzt irgendwo auf der Welt, wo das nicht so äh so viel sequenziert wird, ja, keine Ahnung, irgendwelchen,
sehr entfernten Landstrichen Afrikas oder so, wo du einfach nicht so eine hohe medizinische äh Infrastruktur hast, mit der so was ähm oft ähm analysiert wird,
Ist aber eher unwahrscheinlich, weil die ja auch jetzt nicht so die hohen Bevölkerungszahlen haben et cetera. Ähm.
Dann halt die Variante äh dass es in immungeschwächten Patienten stattfindet,
also die Möglichkeit, dass das Virus lange in dem Körper einer einzelnen Person bleibt, weil das Immunsystem zu schwach ist, das Virus so weit zurückzuschlagen, um's dann wirklich mit den Teezellen irgendwann zu killen,
wenn's einem vorher nicht selbst gekillt hat, das heißt, es äh lebt dort weiter und passt sich dann wunderbar ähm
an diese Person quasi an, um von der immer wieder weglaufen zu können und gerät dann irgendwann aus dieser Person wieder heraus und verpflanzt sich weiter fort.
Und die dritte These ist halt Tiere. Ne? Das ist halt irgendein Tier gibt.
Äh diese Variante durchgegangen ist und jetzt gibt's halt einen Paper, was sich das mal genau angeschaut hat, was eigentlich hier so bei Omicron für Mutationen so sind und was die so können und wo wozu denn das passen würde.
Deren These ist Mäuse.
Mhm. Aber wir wollten doch nicht über die Theorie reden, oder?
Nein, das.
Hat jetzt mit Labor nichts zu tun, sondern hier kann es sich halt auch einfach ganz normale Hausmäuse äh handeln,
Ja, die also in irgendeiner Form in der Nähe äh von von Menschenleben und ähm was dafür spricht ist, dass halt der.
Ähm diese Mutation von dem Spike Protein von Omikron äh sehr gut passend zu Mäusen.
So ne und ähm.
Sich dann vielleicht in der Population eine Weile äh weiterentwickelt hat und dann halt wieder äh Escape ist.
Also äh neben mit den Mäusen habe ich auf jeden Fall auch gehört. Äh so das habe ich auch gelesen, dass sozusagen der Omega zwischen Wirth äh Mäuse gewesen sein könnten.
O-Mikron.
O-Mikron O-Mikro.
Wir sind noch nicht bei Omega.
Ähm so.
Ist das so schwer?
Ja äh irgendwie,
äh versuche ich das seit seit Wochen äh so passiert mir das auch im im Schreiben, weil ich halt auch ich ich äh durchaus
Omega auch eine ganze Menge verwendet habe als Buchstaben äh so für Dinge. Ähm so.
Ja und um ja eher selten so äh.
Ähm ja äh nee, die Frage ist, okay, waren's jetzt zivile Mäuse oder waren die irgendwie äh.
So staatlich beschäftigte äh Mäuse äh die Arbeit in irgendwelchen Laboren äh äh äh gemacht äh äh haben, ja.
Mäuse halt. Also ich meine es ist jetzt ist ist ist ein Paper, das ist auch schon irgendwie periviewd, also es ist schon äh jetzt nicht irgend so eine so ein so.
Windiges Video, sondern das das hat jetzt wirklich mal äh.
Ich habe mir das Paper natürlich im Detail nicht durchgelesen. Soll wohl auch ein sehr kompliziertes äh Paper sein. Ähm aber ähm,
da lässt sich das sozusagen schon ablesen. Das ist jetzt kein Beweis, dass das so ist. Das ist halt einfach Evidence so. Den haben sie halt äh gefunden und.
Kann man jetzt erstmal nur so zur zur Kenntnis nehmen, ne, dass das jetzt hier äh die Quelle ist. Also Link auf Papper haben wir auch
und auch noch auf ein Video, was das äh analysiert hier von unserem
Freund John Campbell, dessen Art ich ja dann doch sehr zu schätzen äh gelernt habe in den letzten Wochen
der einfach äh mit Betonlichkeit durch diese ganzen Sachen durchstiefelt und ja so seine eigenen Analysen noch dazu bringt.
Jetzt vielleicht auch nicht immer in allen Fällen. Jetzt super richtig liegt, aber äh so aber generell äh hat das schon Hand und Fuß, würde ich sagen, was von sich gibt.
Ja, also der würde auf jeden Fall auch seine Fehler äh sofort eingestehen und tut das auch, wenn äh wenn es so ist, ne.
Was bei diesen ganzen ähm Übersichten dann auch noch ähm herauskam.
Also neue Studien, die das sozusagen äh belegen, dass äh offensichtlich und das ist.
Das ist wirklich jetzt sehr interessant, ja. Also das man würde sich das jetzt gar nicht denken. Ich habe ja eben noch erzählt, oh Mikron hat sich,
vielleicht über einen längeren Zeitraum. Also letzte Mal, also die die letzte Ursprungsvariante, die äh in irgendeiner Form noch.
Verwandtschaft hat. Ja, also die in irgendeiner Form ein Vorläufer gewesen sein kann von OmiCronn. Die ist halt zuletzt gesehen worden.
20.
Sommer 20 20.
Ja, also wirklich ganzer und dann war sie weg. So und jetzt nach über einem Jahr taucht die halt äh auf und.
Offensichtlich irgendwo da in Botswana, Südafrika, so diese Gegend, da muss es irgendwie gewesen sein, ne.
Und wo Leute sagen wir mal auch in Kontakt kommen mit mit solchen äh Tieren auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise, ja und ähm an die Eigenschaften sind halt bemerkenswert. Also,
es ist wahrscheinlich haben wir einfach oder was ich abzeichne, sagen wir's mal so, ist, dass wir irre viel Schwein gehabt haben.
Also das das ist ja jetzt alles noch nicht zu Ende, aber wir haben's jetzt mit einer Variante zu tun, die die sich lange vor uns versteckt hat, die dann irgendwie aus dem Nichts aufgetaucht ist, die dann innerhalb weniger Wochen.
In riesigen Gesellschaften wie Südafrika jetzt grade in UK Dänemark überall also überall wo Mikron auftaucht ersetzt es Delta.
Delta ist, richtig auf dem äh Rückmarsch. Einerseits natürlich, weil Omigrün so sehr viel ansteckender ist und damit natürlich einen Vorteil hat,
Trotzdem verdrängt es Delta auch und jetzt hat man noch mal geguckt, okay was kann äh denn Omi Coin so äh was die Immunität betrifft und es wurde festgestellt, na ja, also erst mal für eine Omikon gehabt hast.
Dann ist natürlich gegen Omikron äh immun das hilft auf jeden Fall gegen. Kriegt man so schnell nicht äh nochmal, das ist ja auch ganz normal.
Aber die Immunität, die von Omicron aufgerufen wird, hilft's interessanterweise auch gegen eine Delta-Infektion.
Obwohl es eigentlich mit Delta gar nix zu tun hat. Ist wirklich irre.
Ja und äh also bei gab eben bisher gut, das ist jetzt nur eine Studie, insofern auch ein bisschen mit Vorsicht zu genießen, aber die Saar.
Erstmal ganz ganz plausibel aus und äh da kam halt äh raus, dass
ungefähr dir ja eine eine
OmiCon-Infektionen einen Schutzfaktor von, sagen wir, drei bis vier äh gegenüber einer Delta,
Infektionen liefert, also ich sage mal so gut ist wie New Johnson Johnson Impfung gegen Delta, ja also ist eine Omi-Kron Infektion so kann man das ungefähr.
Vergleichen in der in der Größenordnung, aber umgekehrt eben nicht. So also äh sagen wir wenn du Delta hattest, dann hast du
nur ein ungefähr einen Schutz von 1,3 gegen vor Ansteckung äh jetzt
schwere Verläufe ist wahrscheinlich nochmal, steht nochmal aufm anderen
Blätter sieht so aus, dass eine, ich sage mal Delta oder oder andere Vorinfektionen, die ja auch einen Schutzfaktor von 2 bis 3 gegenüber Hospitalisierung bringt, aber sagen der Ansteckungsschutz
ist halt äh nach einer durchgemachten äh Delta äh eben
äh äh nicht so groß. Das heißt, wenn wenn man sich jetzt covid holt, sollte man sich jetzt äh möglichst nicht noch eine Delta abholen. Das wäre irgendwie blöd, weil man sich danach nämlich trotzdem noch eine Omi-Kron.
Genau. Jetzt neu zwei Infektionen in einer.
Ja äh genau, also dann lieber erst die Omi-Kron und dann ist gut sein äh also wenn man jetzt sich eine Variante holen will, dann ist das auf jeden Fall die Unikron. Ähm.
Rufen Sie jetzt die Nummer neben Ihrer Landesflagge an. Bestellen Sie OmiCrorn.
Mhm genau, nein, man will's natürlich am besten gar nicht haben. Und.
Auch noch so ein bisschen unklar ist äh natürlich,
so wie sich das denn auswirkt, wenn man so mit kleineren Mengen von von O-Mikron in Kontakt äh kommt, ohne dass man sich dabei wirklich infiziert, ob das irgendwie hilft
Aber wahrscheinlich äh so richtig
äh helfen dürfte wahrscheinlich einen entsprechendes äh vaxin, was ja hoffentlich im März dann.
Auch zur Verfügung steht. Ähm und gut, eine große Frage äh war natürlich dann dann auch sagen,
Wenn jetzt Omikron kommt, kann äh kann dann hinterher wieder dann eine Deltawelle äh kommen und äh ich sage mal grundsätzlich ja aber ist eher unwahrscheinlich.
Aber es gibt natürlich andere Mutationen noch. Ich glaube zum Beispiel die Beta äh äh Variante, die jetzt nicht so super erfolgreich war, aber äh da schützt halt um Mikro-Infektion wohl nicht so gut vor.
Ja aber bitter gibt's ja nicht mehr.
Ja, äh aber ja also jedenfalls bei uns nicht, aber heißt nicht, dass es die noch irgendwo.
In der Welt grassiert und.
Dann äh nicht doch wieder wieder kommen könnte. Also oder eine eine nicht die nicht die Beta-Variante an sich, aber vielleicht eine, die sozusagen eher auf irgendetwas passiert, was aussieht wie Beta.
Was auf jeden Fall noch mal ganz interessant ist, ist mal zu schauen, wie's jetzt eigentlich den Ländern geht, wo OmiCronn jetzt schon äh gewütet hat oder noch wütet. Das ist natürlich vor allem Südafrika.
Und ähm da hat man jetzt also festgestellt, dass äh die also erstmal die Welle ist da schon wieder durch.
Und äh während diese Welle da war, hat sich also OmiCronn locker mal so viermal so schnell verbreitet wie Delta.
Also enorm viel schneller und hat deutlich weniger schwere Fälle verursacht. Na,
immer alles mit ein bisschen Grain of Salt nehmen, weil dort halt hohe Herdenimmunität sowohl durch ähm Wildtyp,
Beta-Variante und Delta-Variante war, ne? Aber ist ja in der Lage eigentlich alles zu überlaufen, von daher ist auch dort,
quasi mehr oder weniger alles nochmal auf null gestellt gewesen. Trotzdem halt weniger schwere Fälle. Und jetzt sind die Infektionen
Südafrika deutlich rückläufig. Auch die Krankenhausbelegungen sind rückläufig, es gab kaum Tote in der vierten Welle.
Und mittlerweile sind sie so entspannt in Südafrika, dass dort Contact Racing ausgesetzt worden äh ist, weil man einfach sagt, Containment ist mit Omicron sowieso nicht realistisch. Das kriegst du einfach gar nicht mehr eingefangen, ja. Es sei denn, du äh bist halt,
schon auf einem hohen Maßnahmen äh Level wie jetzt in äh Deutschland und äh da geht's jetzt schon sehr viel mehr ähm nur noch um die Medikation, also wie können wir sozusagen mit dem was ist aus äh löst
umgehen. Äh man hat einen extrem hohen Anteil, also symptomatischer Fälle, also du kriegst es halt auch einfach gar nicht äh äh mit und ja
wenig überraschend, geht man davon aus, dass also eine extrem starke Verbreitung über äh Ario Sole stattfindet, dass das OmiCron wohl,
seiner Anpassung einfach noch sehr viel länger in der Luft hängt. Ähm von daher kann man halt auch generell sagen, Abstandsregelungen.
Diese eins ,fünf Meter, also es macht mich einfach irre, wenn ich das jetzt irgendwie immer noch sehe, ne? Das ist das.
Muss jetzt einfach fallen. Das ist einfach Quatsch
Also wenn's indoor ist und man will verhindern, dass Leute sich da anstecken, dann hilft diese Abstandsregel einen Scheiß, sondern was hilft, sind Masken und
Punkt so, das ist alles, ne und,
Lüftung und Filter und so weiter. Das hilft alles so, ne? Aber irgendwelche aufm Boden aufgeklebt und halten sie jetzt irgendwie eine andere Mitte Abstand, weil dann irgendwas anders sein soll. Das kann man einfach mal komplett
vergessen und ich hoffe das wird auch diesmal gemacht. Ich hatte die absurde Situation ich war in so einem Schwimmbad und in diesem Schwimmbad haben die dann,
Wegen dieser Abstandsregelung so gefühlt 80 Prozent aller Umkleide.
Schränke gesperrt, dass man die nicht benutzen darf.
Dass sozusagen auf ganz wenige reduziert. Ja, was natürlich dann zur Folge hatte, dass sich dann alle um diese Wenigen herum äh gescharrt haben. Äh also.
Und das macht einfach auch hinten und vorne alles überhaupt gar keinen äh Sinn mehr, ne. Na gut, zurück zu äh Südafrika.
Südafrika wollte ich aber noch sagen, was man immer aber bei Vergleichen beachten sollte mit Südafrika ist, dass sie generell dort eine viel jüngere Bevölkerung noch haben,
so äh dass es dass es definitiv ähm die eine Sache, äh die man nicht vergessen sollte und die zweite ist, dass dort jetzt Sommer herrscht.
Aber es ist ja mittlerweile auch so auch in UK sehen wir ein ähnliches Bild.
Also auch dort ist äh das sehr schnell durchgelaufen. Äh die Geschwindigkeit der Infektion war sehr hoch oder ist auch noch sehr hoch. Äh trotzdem auch dort ist kein nennenswerter Druck
kein nennenswerter zusätzlicher Druck auf die Krankenhäuser bisher zu sehen. Schwere Fälle äh gehen zurück. Also klar auch hier greift der Vergleich nicht. Die sind zwar jetzt nicht mehr so jung
Ja, so ähm vielleicht vom Altersschnitt her zumindest vergleichbar mit Deutschland, aber die haben halt eine höhere Impfquote. Gut,
Ja, also auch bei den Älteren. Das ist halt das, was wir bei uns ab äh warten müssen, aber mir ging's ja jetzt erst mal nur darum
Was macht OmiCronn halt real in diesen Ländern und da sieht man halt im Vergleich zu vorher ähm passiert es halt ähm dass da einfach die Dinge anders laufen und dass sie auch die Politik ändert. Interessant ist zum Beispiel ein Blick nach
Australien. Australien gehört ja nun zu diesen Ländern, die so eine extreme No-
covid oder zero covid, wie man's auch nennen möchte, Low-Covid-Strategie verfolgt haben, genauso wie Neuseeland.
Ja, die also sehr schnell Lockdowns lokal gemacht haben, sehr schnell drauf reagiert haben, aber auch in der Regel innerhalb von eins ähzwei, drei Tagen die Situation dann auch wieder in den Griff bekommen haben und,
jetzt mit Omicron, konnten sie natürlich auch nicht verhindern, dass es irgendwie ins Land kommt. Jetzt ist es halt so, dass sie sagen, so, das machen wir jetzt nicht mehr.
Lassen wir das irgendwie laufen, auch in Australien gehen die äh Fälle rasant nach oben. Da muss ich jetzt tatsächlich noch mal
tagesaktuell gerade schauen, äh wie es da jetzt eigentlich gerade genau äh aussieht, um hier mal eine Aussage.
Machen zu können und während ich das so
galant nebenbei äh erzählt habe, liegt die Grafik mir auch schon vorab mit Deutschland vergleicht, das geht einfach mal durch die Decke, ja. Also das ist mal so im Vergleich zu äh Deutschland, also Faktor vier
die gemessene äh Infektion, ja, also ewig haben die sich in einem sehr, sehr, sehr niedrigen
Bereich gehalten, also der der Höchststand an gemessenen Infektionen der Australien überhaupt hatte. Das war so der niedrigste Stand in Deutschland zwischen dritter und vierter Welle.
Und äh jetzt geht es halt einfach ab und die sehen halt auch, okay, alles klar, mit funktioniert diese No-Covid-Strategie nicht mehr
Also das das das kann man jetzt einfach vergessen und äh dementsprechend machen sie das halt auch nicht mehr,
sondern sagen jetzt, okay, wir wir beobachten das einfach und konzentrieren uns auf Metication, äh anstatt Containment so, wir gucken jetzt einfach, wie's läuft und äh bisher
läuft's noch nicht in einem bedrohlichen Maß, also hohe Infektionszahlen, klar. Das äh definitiv, aber eben,
nicht entsprechend hohe Todeszahlen oder also irgendein Anstalten der äh äh von langfristigen schweren Fällen im im Krankenhaus, ne.
Wie sieht denn da die Impfquote aus?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich glaube, sie ist relativ hoch, aber ich weiß es nicht genau, lass mich kurz gucken.
Vacinated, also die Impfquote
liegt bei sechsundsiebzig ,neun im Vergleich Deutschland 70, also ja 77 zu 71.
Also höher und Booster.
Dosis, da sind sie noch hinterher. Also da sind sie noch nicht so weit wie äh Deutschland und sind gerade mal bei zwölf Prozent.
Äh Sie haben ja auch eher später angefangen, wenn ich mich entsinne, oder? Nee, mit dem Impfen überhaupt äh dort, weil sie ja keinen covid hatten. Äh war ja äh irgendwie erstmal.
Genau, also Parität haben die äh am 5. November, Anfang November haben die dieselbe Impfquote gehabt,
Also sie haben so richtig erst gefühlt, würde ich sagen mit naja,
hm zwei Monaten Verspätung losgelegt und haben uns im November eingeholt und mittlerweile deutlich überholt. Also Australien ist wirklich ein Land, wo man sich äh einiges abgucken kann. Aber ist ja auch eine Insel, ne? Ist ja alles anders.
Ja ja, genau.
Und man spricht Englisch, was auch immer alles bedeutet. Ja, also was sagt uns das? Ähm.
Es gibt es gibt es gibt Anlass zur Hoffnung. Ich will's mal so formulieren. Ähm.
Habe ich äh in einem anderen Podcast jetzt schon mal zu der Aussage hinreißen lassen. In zwei Monaten ist alles vorbei.
So wird's nicht sein, nicht in dem Sinne, dass alles vorbei ist und ähm die Truppen sind abgezogen und man wundert sich, was hier überhaupt passiert ist. Sondern.
Es wird mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit, wenn jetzt nicht
noch irgendwie aus dem Nichts heraus eine noch übertragbarere Variante daherkommt, die auf einmal wieder ganz viel Schaden macht und in der Lage ist OmiCron zu verdrängen, weil sowas nicht passiert,
Was ich nicht wissen kann, was passieren kann, aber was nicht besonders wahrscheinlich ist.
So wie Omi Coint schon nicht besonders wahrscheinlich war, aber jetzt eben trotzdem passiert ist, dann wird es jetzt durchlaufen. Es wird über die Welt.
Herfallen. Es wird Länder im Sturm nehmen. Es wird in Deutschland selbst wenn wir uns jetzt hier massiv noch mit.
Maßnahmen bis in den Februar versuchen dagegen zu stemmen, was vielleicht auch ganz sinnvoll ist das zu tun, wenn wir trotzdem hier diese fünfte Welle,
meiner Meinung nach so im Februar dann wieder abflauen sehen. Mit sehr hohen Infektionszahlen.
So und dann äh ja dann ist äh wirklich der Marsch zur Herdenimmunität langsam äh realistisch.
Sodass wir also so die äh sagenumwobene endemische Situation vielleicht hergestellt haben können. Wie viele ältere Leute in dem Zuge jetzt noch dran glauben müssen,
keine Ahnung. Ja, das ist halt das Problem, die Leute sind nicht geimpft
Wenn nicht geimpft ist, geht einfach ein vielfach hoheres äh Risiko ein. Inwiefern,
Kinder äh stärker betroffen sein werden von Omicron
auch nicht sagen. Es ist auf jeden Fall so, dass die höhere Infektiösität von omikron, dazu führt, dass eben Kinder in einem ganz anderen Maße eben mit infiziert werden. Das sehen wir aus den aktuellen Zahlen heraus und das
ähm sind ja auch Berichte aus allen Ländern, wo Omikron um sich gegriffen hat,
Kinder eben sehr viel mehr hier mit in die Rechnung mit reingenommen werden äh müssen
was es dann für Auswirkungen hat, wie schnell jetzt hier die äh Impfungen der Jüngeren da äh entsprechend gegenhalten kann. Das kann glaube ich derzeit keiner sagen. Das werden wir einfach abwarten müssen. Nur.
An dieser Durchseuchung mit Omicron werden wir nichts ändern können.
Könnten wir jetzt nur, indem wir jetzt so eine totale no covid äh ach jetzt machen wir noch mal zwei Monate Lockdown-Strategie verfolgen und das ist einfach total äh unrealistisch und in gewisser Hinsicht auch unnötig.
Jedenfalls äh ja, muss man äh sagen äh.
Berlin sagt die Hospitalisierungszahlen bisher. Äh ich meine nicht, dass das jetzt.
Entspannt wäre äh so, aber ähm so ist es eben,
ja äh wir sind im Vergleich äh zu den vorherigen äh Wellen so ähm ja ist es noch im gelben Bereich bisher. Was nicht heißt, dass wir nicht auch in den roten Bereich noch kommen können so.
Aber äh ja ähm.
Sieht halt nicht so aus.
Wie du schon sagtest, es gibt gute Hoffnungen, dass wir mit dem blauen Auge jetzt davon kommen so.
Ja, da haben wir wirklich dann mehr mehr Glück als Verstand gehabt.
Ja. Haben wir noch was äh nachzutragen zum Thema Omni.
Ja na ja man vielleicht sagen wer aber trotzdem vielleicht cool wenn.
Wir weiter zusehen, äh dass halt auch die Welt geimpft wird. Ähm,
So, weil äh einfach auch um wieder weitere, überraschende Varianten
vielleicht ja deren Wahrscheinlichkeit zu reduzieren, weil noch stellen wir halt diesen Virus massiv Rechenleistung zur Verfügung.
Was dann natürlich die Wahrscheinlichkeit neuer, cleverer Varianten äh durchaus erhöht und eigentlich müssten wir dieses Virus irgendwie mal ein bisschen jetzt äh ja von der Rechenleistung langsam abschneiden.
Äh damit wir nicht immer mit neuen Varianten rechnen müssen. Eigentlich nicht so sehr rechnen müssen.
Ja, der Gewürz ist jetzt noch ein äh interessanten neuen Kriegsschauplatz äh geben. Was vielleicht das falsche Wort, aber äh weißt du, was ich meine?
Nein.
Na ja, ich meine, es gibt ja nun ein Land, was ich bisher.
Auf eine interessante Art und Weise aus dem ganzen Covid-Geschehen rausgehalten hat, obwohl's eigentlich von Anfang an mit im Boot war, nämlich China.
Ja, okay.
Und äh natürlich wird es auch China jetzt sehr schwer fallen sich OmiCronn vom Hals zu halten aus den genannten Gründen.
Ja, also ihre Methode, äh Zero-Covid äh durchzusetzen mit maximalen Lockdowns. Die ist anstrengend,
und die wird auch an ihre Grenzen kommen. Es gab jetzt wegen Omigrant glaube ich auch schon wieder so ein,
totalen Lockdown. Ich habe jetzt den Namen der Stadt leider gerade nicht äh parat. Es war halt nicht Wuhan, sondern halt woanders.
Und ähm na ja gut, den Tanz können Sie sicherlich noch eine Weile machen. Ihre Impfstoffe, die Sie im mehrheitlich verimpft haben, sind nicht sonderlich
durchschlagskräftig gegen OmiCronn, also im Prinzip sind sie gegen OmiCrollen relativ also gegen Infektionen überhaupt nicht geschützt und gegen Fälle weiß ich nicht, ob's da überhaupt schon Erkenntnisse gibt, aber
am 4. Februar ist die Eröffnungsfeier der äh Olympischen Winterspiele in China.
Mhm.
So und das ist natürlich ein großes äh Event, wo die Welt zu Gast sein soll. So der Plan. Aber wo dann zumindest natürlich viele jubelnde Chinesen irgendwie rumstehen äh sollen und ähm.
Noch nicht so ganz klar, wie sieht das jetzt laufen lassen wollen, aber hm das könnte ein interessanter Tanz werden sich hier gleichzeitig mit Lockdowns gegen ähm.
Gegen äh so eine Variante schützen zu wollen, aber auf der anderen Seite so eine international fiel beachtete äh Tagesveranstaltung durchzuführen.
Ja, das äh wird in der Tat äh wirklich spannend äh werden. Ich meine, sowieso China ist ist sowieso ein Thema irgendwie für sich äh so und ähm.
Gut, äh diese die die Stadt war glaube ich äh Chian oder wie auch.
Ja Shian, glaube ich.
Ausspricht äh und ähm.
Es gab auch Berichte darüber, dass dieser Lockdown nicht nur äh wegen covid, sondern dass sie auch einen Ausbruch von himoralischem Fieber dort hatten.
Also im Prinzip ja ja so ich sage mal Ebola oder äh äh Konsorten. So ja.
In der Kategorie läuft das oder wie?
Also himoralisches Fieber Marburg äh Virus äh und so wo du dann wo dann anfängt sozusagen du anfängst aus allen Körperöffnungen zu bluten und äh ja.
So dieses diese Sorte und.
Daher sollen sie wohl irgendwie auch ein paar Dutzend Fälle von himorangischem Fieber äh äh gehabt äh haben. Was äh ja,
ähm sagen zeitgleich zu covid und wo dann wiederum das sozusagen die die das Gerücht äh kam, dass sie halt das
quasi Corona nur vorgeschoben haben für diesen harten Lockdown, sondern in Wirklichkeit Angst hatten wegen dem hemorarischen Fieber.
Aber das halt nicht äh eine große Glocke hängen wollten, aber.
Ja, ich bin gespannt. Also vielleicht heißt es ja dann covid is coming home, ja? Also ähm werden wir sehen. Oder auch nicht. Willst du's gut verstecken.
Ja, wolltest du noch was zu der Kinderdiskussion beitragen oder nicht.
Ja kommt man also das ist halt wie gesagt eine eine ganz ganz schwierige äh Debatte. Ich.
Erstmal um vorweg zu sagen, würde meine Kinder schon impfen lassen, so. Ähm.
Aber äh hatten wir vorhin schon das Thema einerseits, was so so Impfpflicht äh angeht ähm ja ähm halte ich,
dass für.
Trotzdem unangemessen bei Jugendlichen oder Kindern. Ähm die zweite Frage ist dann aber äh sagen jetzt oder Kontroverse geht natürlich jetzt zwischen ähm.
Offen halten der Schulen und äh durchinfizieren lassen. Jetzt äh der der Kinder quasi und,
ja da hatten wir eben auch, dass dass wir jetzt
äh wissen, da kam jetzt eine Meldung, äh ging ging jetzt so rum, die auch so in, ich sage mal, Impfgegnerkreisen
oder in äh Corona-Skeptikerkreisen, wie auch immer äh dann auch viel rumgereicht wurde, wo äh.
Ja ist jetzt eine eine Studie gab äh von Intensivärzten wo wohl rauskamen, dass dann nach der zweiten Welle etwa
äh die Zahl der Kinder, die äh wegen Selbstmordversuchen auf Intensivstationen liegen.
Um Faktor 4, also 400 Prozent angestiegen.
Ist so. Interessanterweise nicht in der nicht während des ersten Lockdowns, während des ersten Lockdowns sind sogar wohl Selbstmordversuche unter Kindern zurückgegangen.
Aber eben in der zweiten Welle, die dann auch so ewig gedauert äh hat. Äh da kann man dann vielleicht.
Auch noch äh dann interpretieren oder ähm dass ich sage mal einen einen kurzer
schneller, effektiver Lockdown äh hat halt zu weniger als Selbstmorden geführt und ein halbgarer ähm sagen
ewiger äh zäher äh Lockdown hat dann äh tatsächlich äh ja
auch dann unter Kindern offenbar zu äh äh massiven Depressionen und Belastungen geführt oder vorhandene äh äh Belastungen verstärkt,
so und ähm ja äh also,
Ich sage, das äh Lockdown äh ist eben äh.
Nicht schön, beziehungsweise die gesamte Belastung äh natürlich durch die Pandemie und selbst auch wenn man äh keine
Lockdowns macht oder so, geht ja davon die Belastung äh für viele nicht äh runter, weil bestimmte
ja Branchen oder so leiden halt trotzdem äh drunter und Leute ändern ihr Verhalten äh äh trotzdem.
So also insofern ist das jetzt auch nicht notwendigerweise einen völlig valides Argument gegen die Maßnahmen, sondern es ist eigentlich
eher ein Argument Maßnahmen halt so zu gestalten, dass sie auch effektiv
wirken und nicht allzu lange anhalten äh äh müssen so. Das und wir haben offensichtlich dann mit dem schlimmsten Weg äh
gewählt, ja, weil ja einerseits ja achtzigtausend Tote zugelassen haben da in der zweiten Welle. Also unter dem Aspekt waren wir nicht besonders gut, sondern eher mittelmäßig, aber dann auch unter dem Aspekt jetzt
ähm Lockdown
Leid äh sage ich mal, war der äh zumindest für die Kinder alles andere als Leid. Ne, insofern ähm ja wieder auch gerade natürlich ein schwieriges Dilemma.
Auch was die Maßnahmen äh jetzt äh angeht und.
Ich denke, äh ja, wir werden uns da leider auch jetzt irgendwie nicht nicht anders können als uns da jetzt irgendwie durchmogeln. Äh äh durchzumogeln und auf sich zu fahren und
die Strategie jetzt täglich zu testen
halte ich für richtig und gut und brauchbar und da hatten wir auch früher nur geredet, dass gerade so in geschlossenen Gruppen, wenn man dann tatsächlich äh ähm,
regelmäßig testet, dann kann das tatsächlich was bringen ähm und wenn das jetzt gefahren wird äh wird man
sehen äh so ob dann noch genug gesunde äh Schüler und Lehrer bleiben, um so etwas wie Unterricht äh äh überhaupt machen zu können, aber.
Ich denke,
ja äh der den Versuch Unternehmen äh sollte man zumindest oder ja ähm nach nach alldem äh was was wir,
was wir wissen, was an Belastungen jetzt jetzt auch äh von ausgeht, aber ähm wir sind ja
bereits auch gerade wieder in so einer Situation drin, je nach Bundesland, je nach je nach Gegend, wo sich das Leben auch schon wieder etwas äh
eingeschränkt anfühlt. Obwohl das nicht wirklich für Berlin gilt, muss ich sagen.
Das mag jetzt jeder auch anders äh empfinden, ne. Je nachdem in welcher beruflichen Situation und sonstigen äh gesellschaftlichen oder privaten Situationen äh ist. Ich meine, das alles so ein bisschen leid sind, ist äh ist klar, ne. Aber ich würde schon sagen,
Dass eine Impfung für die Kinder jetzt äh sehr geboten ähm ist, ne? Es gibt auch Todesfälle. Sie sind halt nicht viele so, aber es äh,
tritt auf. Es ist immer noch alles sehr unklar.
Wie das so mit Pinsel und Covid et cetera äh weitergeht und es gibt auf der anderen Seite sehr viele Untersuchungen, die immer wieder jetzt ähm nahelegen, dass halt auch normale Infektionen, ja, die auch vielleicht äh in Anführungsstrichen milde verlaufen, schon auch noch langfristige Auswirkungen auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise
haben, ne, bei Delta mehr als jetzt äh vielleicht bei Omikrollen, dafür kommt eben Omikron schneller äh heran durch diese hohe Infektion. Infektiösität,
reicht es halt auch Personen, eben auch jüngere Personen, die vielleicht andere Varianten so gar nicht erst erreicht haben und äh von daher ist es eine,
Schwere hm oder vielleicht gar nicht so schwere Einschätzung, aber für mich ist es relativ leicht. Ich würde würde dieses ähm,
wird die Impfung auf jeden Fall immer wählen so, aber ist auf jeden Fall ein Argument, was man noch mal mit reinziehen sollte, wenn man da in irgendeiner Form zurückhaltend ist.
Und man kann vielleicht auch nochmal sagen funktionales logisches Argument bringen. Ein Effekt.
Einer Impfung, egal in welchem Alter ähm so ist, dass.
Wenn dann eine Infektion erfolgt, dass Immunsystem einfach,
in der Lage ist, schneller äh die Infektion zu bekämpfen.
Das heißt, äh selbst wenn ich sage mal die Impfung äh eine Ansteckung dann nicht verhindert, auch bei Kindern vielleicht nicht verhindert, was sie.
Dann trotzdem schon mal mit einem gewissen Prozentsatz tut, aber selbst wenn sie es nicht tut, bleibt halt dieser Vorteil äh sagen kann, okay, früher oder später wird jeder Kontakt,
mit dem Virus kriegen und dann ist es aber besser äh wenn
Ich äh schon mal eine Impfung gesehen habe oder mein mein Immunsystem äh schon mal
sagen Teile von dem Virus gesehen hat und dann eben genau vermeidet
dass sich das erst in allen möglichen Organen ausbreitet und dort Schäden äh verursacht, sondern auch die Ausbreitung äh so äh äh wird halt äh,
eingedämmt, äh wenn es dann zur Infektion kommt, was äh dann logischerweise auch äh bedeutet, weniger Gefahr von äh Gesundheitsschäden.
Und das gilt glaube ich für alle,
auch für ich sage mal Kinder mit einem gesunden oder starken Immunsystem äh wie man dann vielleicht gerne mal postuliert oder wie ist das, wie ist das äh durchaus auch,
gibt. Ähm auch da ist es so, dass äh ja, dass.
Covid Virus hat halt gewisse Mechanismen, die sich erst mal äh die dazu führen, dass sie sich erst mal vor bestimmten Immunantworten verstecken kann. Das heißt, es ist erst mal in der Lage, sich unbemerkt auszubreiten.
Ähm,
Und äh das äh wird halt verhindert, weil quasi schon mal Steckbriefe aushängen und äh die Viren dann, wenn sie dann eindringen halt früher erkannt werden und deswegen Moment mal irgendwie
die kennen wir doch sehen aber verdächtig aus die wollen wir nicht und
ja in im anderen Fall wie gesagt ohne ohne,
vorherige Impfung äh kann das Virus halt äh das den den Körper äh weiter und tiefer infiltrieren, bevor es dann äh sagen die Sicherheitsbehörden aufmerksam werden und Gegenmaßnahmen ergreifen.
So kann man sich das vielleicht vorstellen. Ja.
Gut ähm ich habe mich dann, ich äh hatte mir noch einige Sachen zu Paxlowit äh notiert.
Zu diesem neuen äh Medikament. Äh wir hatten das hier schon ein paar Mal angesprochen und ich habe jetzt leider äh,
Mehr Notizen gefunden, als ich äh als ich erwartet hatte. Irgendwie das Gefühl habe, so wiederhole ich mich jetzt irgendwie oder nicht
Ähm die eigentliche Nachricht, die wir so, glaube ich, noch nicht gebracht haben, ist, dass dieses Medikament, also wir reden jetzt von dem Medikament gegen eine ähm bereits erfolgte,
Also gegen die Ausbreitung einer bereits erfolgten Covid-Infektion innerhalb der ersten Tage von Symptomen.
Wenn sich jetzt jemand mit dem Coronavirus infiziert und dann irgendwie Symptome entwickelt und die Gefahr besteht so, ah hier.
Ältere Personen, schwächere Personen immungeschwächte Personen, was auch immer.
Ähm äh lieber mal was dagegen tun, damit es nicht noch schlimmer wird, dann steht eben jetzt
dieses Medikament theoretisch muss man sagen, zur Verfügung, weil die Verfügbarkeit äh der ersten Dahlung ist überschaubar und ähm natürlich haben viele Länder da schon vorbestellt. Also es wird erstmal nicht
genug geben und unter Umständen für den Bedarf aber wenn die halt vorliegen dann können die eben zum äh.
Einsatz kommen und ähm ja ist ganz interessant wie äh das wirkt. Deutschland hat eine Million.
Jetzt hätte ich fast Dosierungen gesagt also Behandlungspackungen gesagt das ist sozusagen das komplette Set was man über eine Behandlungsdauer von ein paar Tagen eben benötigt also mehrere Tabletten pro Tag an zu mehreren Zeitpunkten
und äh das hatten wir ja hier auch schon,
erwähnt, dass das äh im Prinzip zwei Wirkstoffe sind, die dann gemeinsam genommen werden müssen. Das eine ist halt der eigentliche Wirkstoff, der halt gegen ähm gegen das Virus
arbeitet,
dadurch, dass eben nach Eindringen des Virus in die Zelle in diesen Prozess der Replikation.
Griffen wird. Ja, also das Virus hat die Zelle bereits erreicht und in den Zellen geht's halt los hier mit jetzt produzieren wir mal neue Viren. Das ist ja das eigentliche Problem, mit dem man dann Probleme bekommt äh im Körper.
Und äh äh das ist halt im Wesentlichen die äh Replikation eben von RNA-Strängen, die dort
produziert werden und in diesem Prozess muss es eben äh so eine bestimmte Prothease muss zum Einsatz kommen. Also ein Stoff, der quasi so einen langen produzierten Strang in kleinere Teile äh
aufteilt
und Paxo wird es halt einen Wirkstoff, der eben genau diese Prothease blockiert, der sich also da so wie Antikörper sich ans eigentliche Virus randocken, dockt sich eben dieses Medikament, in dem Moment an,
diese Prothease-Proteine ran und verhindert quasi diesen Replikationsprozess.
Ich habe ein paar ähm habe ein Video verlinkt, wo das auch nochmal sehr schön im Detail äh erläutert wird, wenn da sogar noch ein zweites angeschaut, wo das dann irgendwie auch mal so richtig auf dem Molekül-Level,
erklärt wird und da.
Habe ich dann nur noch Fiepen in den Ohren gehabt, also das da da war ich dann irgendwie komplett raus. Ist immer wieder schön, wenn man in so Nordbereiche eintaucht, wo man dann so merkt so, okay.
Fehlt dir jegliches Wissen und jegliche Grundlage und du verstehst einfach überhaupt gar nichts mehr. Also ich wusste in etwa worüber sie reden so aber
jetzt hier wann wo welche chemische Verbindung worandockt und wie sich das irgendwie in dreißig Schritten äh wie das so zusammengebaut wird. Das fand ich schon bemerkenswert. Also auch gerade das hat mir auch einen gewissen Respekt nochmal vor medizinischer
von Medikamentenproduktion also pharmakologischer Produktion einge ähm.
Eingetütet, weil äh diese Prozesse, ja, also um wirklich genau,
diesen Wirkstoff zu produzieren, ja? Dass da so dreißig Schritte nötig sind auf molekularen Level, dass dann hier noch das andockt und dann im nächsten Schritt kann dann das andocken und dann kann das andocken und dann hat man irgendwie eigentlich erst eigentlich einen Wirkstoff. Das fand ich dann doch schon
sehr äh bemerkenswert.
Ja und richtig krass äh wird's dann noch äh wenn du dann in die Neurochemie
reingehst und dann äh sozusagen auch noch so Rezeptoren und äh in Richtung ja Neurotransmitter und und ähnliches äh und Hormonsystem und ähm ja
ähm das ist ist ist wahnsinnig kompliziert.
Na ja, also ich bin auf jeden Fall gespannt, wann äh Paxlowitt wirklich breiten Einsatz findet, weil ich denke, das was äh jetzt von Omicron noch an schweren Fällen übrig gelassen wird, das äh wird dann die Menschheit unter Umständen damit,
bekämpfen können. Da bin ich relativ zuversichtlich, weil die Untersuchungen, die Trials, die sie ja es gab ja
Das erste Mal angesprochen hatte, gab's ja nur die Pressemitteilung von Pfizer und mittlerweile sind äh diese Daten wohl auch veröffentlicht worden und wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Hatten sie halt irgendwie so ein ähm,
randomisierten Doppelblinden, Plazebo basierten Trial mit 3000 Leuten, die halt äh eine frische SARS-CoV-zwei Infektion hatten und die äh milde moderate Symptome hatten.
Zwar nicht im Krankenhaus waren und keine Sauerstoff äh Versorgung haben durften, also die nicht schon in irgendeiner Form,
in so einer aktiven Behandlung waren, mindestens zwölf waren, mindestens 40 Kilo schwer waren und mindestens irgendeinen Risikofaktor hatten, also entweder besonders dick sind oder Krankheit hatten oder so etwas.
Und dann haben sie schon, das hatten wir ja auch schon mal erwähnt, dann haben sie irgendwie schon nach
1219 Leuten, mit denen sie das gemacht hatten, obwohl sie 3000 vorgesehen hatten. Haben sie das äh schon abgebrochen, weil die Ergebnisse so gut waren.
Sie das nicht mehr äh vertreten konnten, den Leuten noch mehr Platz übers zu geben, weil's einfach sehr offensichtlich war, dass es so gut wirkt, dass dass dass sie das einfach ja an der Stelle schon äh beenden konnten.
Ne, also immerhin also wenn Paxlowitt innerhalb von fünf Tagen nach Symptombeginn gegeben wurde, ist keiner gestorben.
Und das ähm ja, das äh sieht also ganz so aus, als ob das für dich ein extrem wirksames Medikament ähm sein wird. Ja und ähm.
Insofern noch mehr Anlass für Optimismus.
Ja, das wäre doch sehr gut, wenn äh das dann auch tatsächlich zum Einsatz käme. Das ist ja immer das andere Problem, dass dann ach neues Medikament äh.
Gut, ich meine, bisher hatten wir ja nur diese monoklonalen Antiviren so und äh abgesehen davon, dass die jetzt mit den neuen Varianten sowieso nicht mehr funktionieren.
Dann halt so. Die mussten dann auch relativ schnell und die mussten sozusagen auch vorab gegeben werden, ne. Also es war ja so für die Situation Ausbruch im Altersheim. Jetzt.
Spritzt man das schon mal Leuten, die noch gar keine Symptome zeigen, weil dann ist es schon wieder zu spät. Und äh jetzt hast du halt Tabletten, die du einfach so einnehmen kannst.
Genau das das Ding ist wahrscheinlich der entscheidende Punkt, dass die anderen Mittel, glaube ich, alle irgendwie intravenös verabreicht äh werden mussten.
Sauteuer waren und dann halt entsprechende Entscheidungen auch gefällt werden muss. Da muss da so einiges zusammenkommen. Das muss jetzt auch immer noch einiges zusammenkommen, aber in dem Moment, wo
Medikamente halt vorrätig sind äh
sie dann halt auch schnell zum Einsatz gebracht werden und dann können sie halt auch zu Hause äh gemacht werden. Also ist jetzt nix, wo man Leute ins Krankenhaus einsperren muss dafür, sondern man sagt einfach so, okay, alles klar, du hast Symptome. Du bist irgendwie gefährdet.
Hast du deinen Satz fünf Tage lang Tabellen äh Tabletten fressen, dann ist alles gut.
Also bin bin gespannt.
Sich das so äh ja in der Praxis werden wird äh oder ob äh ja man da auch wieder zu spät und zu wenig äh irgendwie zugreifen wird, aber wir werden sehen.
Ich würde sagen, dann machen wir heute mal eine kompakte Sendung und ähm können vielleicht noch ein kleines Fazit äh hinterherwerfen. Auch wenn wir schon sehr viel Fazit gezogen haben auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise.
Wir ich denke, so Fazit ist bisher alles im gelben Bereich grade mit.
Ein paar Risiken, aber auch einigen Silberstreifen am Horizont, das das Ganze jetzt der Anfang vom Ende der Pandemie sein könnte, was wir gerade sehen.
Das das denke ich auch äh und ich hoffe einfach nur, dass jetzt nicht nochmal irgendwas kommt, weil,
Da kann man jetzt keine sichere Aussage zu treffen. Also erstmal sind wir da gar nicht äh ausreichend kompetent, um hier irgendwie alle Aspekte
wirklich beurteilen zu können ne auch wir beziehen ja unsere Information primär eigentlich von von Leuten die.
Wie soll ich sagen, so ein bisschen die die Trüffelschweine im Studienwald sind und die.
Ne, sozusagen eine Vorauswahl treffen und auch wissen, was man sich vielleicht nicht anschauen müssen und die dann eben auch zu so einer ähm Debatte äh was beizutragen haben. Auch die können sich natürlich äh auch mal irren.
Und vor allem es kann halt immer wieder irgendwas kommen. Also natürlich ist es möglich, dass morgen irgendwie da so ein super
Virusvariante äh kommt. Ich musste auch schon so ein bisschen schlucken irgendwo in Frankreich. Ist glaube ich äh mal wieder so eine neue Variante äh definiert worden so, aber habe ich jetzt
noch nix weit davon gehört, von daher ist es vielleicht auch nicht äh so wild weiß ich nicht.
Nee, ist auch zu der Variante, auf die bin ich auch gestoßen.
160 für zwei.
Da dachte ich irgendwie auch, och nee, jetzt nicht nicht schon wieder, aber wenn man sich das dann genauer anguckt.
Ist, die erstens gibt es die schon länger. Die ist also jetzt keine neue Variante, sondern die äh das ist die ist vor Monaten
entdeckt worden und man hat jetzt auch nicht mehr als ein paar Dutzend Fälle davon gefunden. Also mit anderen Worten, wenn's die schon seit Monaten gibt, dann ist die nicht besonders erfolgreich gewesen bisher.
Und äh ist also insofern dann äh wahrscheinlich ja war war wieder mehr so eine Pressemeldung, wo dann wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Leute wieder ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit haben wollten.
Für etwas äh was äh die Aufmerksamkeit nicht verdient.
Gut, jemand hat das halt gemeldet, dass es das gibt. Irgendjemand hat das zur Kenntnis genommen. Die waren halt mal drüber berichtet und äh äh das war's dann aber auch, aber also derzeit gibt's halt im Varianten Wald noch nix Wirkliches so, ne, aber es sieht einfach so aus, als ob
OmiCron so ein bisschen der schwarze Ritter. Der der schwarze Ritter aus dem Mäuschenwald äh ist.
Ja, kann sein, ja. Also ähm warum nicht?
Ist zumindest,
eine äh Variante, die glücklicherweise äh Eigenschaften hat, die ein bisschen in die richtige Richtung äh gehen. Das ist halt immer Zufall.
Ähm so, also ob eine Variante jetzt schädlicher ist oder nicht, das ist der Variante erstmal
egal so. Äh außer wenn's dann die gesamte Population aus äh rottet äh so, dann aber vorher äh so lange noch genug Wirte da ist, geht das zufällig in die eine oder in die andere Richtung und bei OmiCron,
ist es eben was zumindest den Schaden, äh den es anrichtet, äh geht es zumindest etwas in die richtige Richtung, ist also nicht gefährlicher, sondern tendenziell eben ticken weniger gefährlich.
Ja Plus dass es glücklicherweise ist es ist zwar auf der einen Seite.
Vorherige Immunität umgeht, aber eben auch nicht völlig.
Also insbesondere, dass der Schutz vor schweren Verläufen bei der Variante auch noch gegeben ist plus dass sie dann eben umgekehrt auch nochmal äh wenn sie einmal durchgelaufen ist ähm,
auch für eine gewisse Immunität gegenüber äh Delta äh sorgt, so dass wo Omikron schon mal war, äh dann auch Delta
nicht mehr so äh leicht erstmal reinkommt. All das sind Dinge, äh wo man sagen kann, ja
so es hätte schlimmer kommen können mit dieser Variante.
Definitiv. Und jetzt hoffen wir mal, dass es nicht noch schlimmer irgendwie.
Mit dieser oder irgendeiner anderen Variante, weil irgendwie Omikon reicht auch. Also es ähm.
Ja.
Ja für die nächste Pandemie brauchen wir noch ein paar Buchstaben, ich weiß nicht alle verbraten.
Gut Leute
Ähm alle Grafiken zu den äh Zahlen am Anfang findet ihr immer im Blog auch alle Links zu den ganzen Studien, die wir jetzt hier äh angesprochen haben oder Berichte dazu oder Twitters dazu. Sind alle immer in den Shownotes.
Hoffe ich immer, dass die alle da drin sind, aber ich denke, wir haben da eine gute Quote. Ähm da könnt ihr nachschlagen, da könnt ihr auch äh Kommentare hinterlassen.
Und ähm.
Ich hoffe, das war für euch erhellend und äh hat euch wieder Einblicke äh geliefert. Äh wie gesagt, wir sind jetzt vorsichtig optimistisch und überhaupt. Man sollte einfach auch optimistisch bleiben. Denn irgendwann ist jede Pandemie zu Ende.
Ja genau und ansonsten ja lasst euch falls ihr es noch nicht seid ist glaube ich grade im Moment eine gute äh Zeit und Gelegenheit das zu tun. Es.
Es hilft äh so auf jeden Fall äh sorgt auch für langfristigen Schutz ähm so denke ich.
Und äh ja, ansonsten lasst euch nicht kirre machen.
Schon gar nicht von uns. Okay, bis bald. Tschüss.
Tschau.